Easter Passover whatever Easter has
arrived and Hollywood is celebrating the
kardashian-jenner family kicked off
their Easter in the desert with Kanye
West's Sunday service at Coachella all
of the sisters seem to match in cream
ensembles Kylie and boyfriend Travis
Scott shared some sweet PDA and after
the service the whole family enjoyed a
fun Easter egg hunt no you got to
collect them mama let's get our Easter
eggs
[Music]
Miley Cyrus shared a few throwbacks
while celebrating the holiday one
topless pic rockin bunny ears and
another adorably yet scary one from her
childhood of her looking like a bunny
you'll be the grandest lady in the
Easter Parade
Emily Ratajkowski hopped around on
Sunday as well in this sultry video for
love magazine meanwhile Nick Jonas and
Priyanka Chopra kept things PG getting
sweet Easter baskets from the original
mrs. Jonas reese witherspoon posted
about her holiday as well showing off
her six-year-old son Tennessee's dapper
blue suit
post Easter egg hunt the kids are so
excited Jessica Simpson debuted the
first photos of her newborn baby girl
birdy made Johnson's adorable face
wearing a floral print Easter dress that
matched her older sister Maxwell Jess
also shared this sweet snap of the
entire squad captioning the pic the
Johnson family party of five
[Music]